hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast applications of
microscopy technology in endodontics
presented by dr. Markovic Gianni dental
researcher at the University of South
Paulo Brazil
I am Kayla Parra market product manager
with Brooker and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is brought to you by lap
routes and sponsored by broker broker
enables scientists to make breakthrough
discoveries and develop new applications
that improve the quality of human life
Brookhurst high performance scientific
instruments and high-value analytical
and diagnostic solutions enable
scientists to explore life and material
at molecular cellular and microscopic
levels for more information please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting a question if you like at any
time you want during the presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and this offers continuing
education credit please click on the
continuing education credit step located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit lastly at the end of the
presentation you will receive a poll
survey which we currently ask you to
complete your answers and suggestions
will help us improve our webinar program
and is greatly appreciated now I would
like to introduce our presenter dr.
Markovic eonni
dr. versi Ani is an invited professor
and researcher at the University of
South Paulo in Brazil he is a certified
specialist in endodontics adapt the
tactics and bioethics and has authored
over 80 peer-reviewed papers in
endodontics dr. Roshini has lectured
worldwide focusing on his main research
interest in root canal anatomy and
endodontic procedures and it's a
pleasure to have him here today for a
complete biography on dr. sacani
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
Marco over to you
hello i'm dr. mark over siani from
brazil today I'll talk about the use of
micro CT in endodontic research
endodontics is a specialty of Dentistry
concerned with the morphology physiology
and pathology of the human dental pulp
and parry radicular tissues to
understand how micro CT can be used to
improve knowledge regarding during the
dots key treatment procedures it is
important to know basically concepts
about the anatomy of teeth a tooth is
made of a number of highly specialized
tissues the enamel is the hard outer
covering visible in the mouth below this
is dentin a less hard and porous
material that makes up the majority of
the tooth in the central part of the
tooth there is a space called the root
canal which contains the pulp tissue
dental pulp is a nominal Isis or a
tissue composite of soft connective
tissue vascular lymphatic and nervous
elements which extends from the pulp
chamber and everything the crown of the
tooth to the tip of the root where it
connects to the tissues around the root
by the apical foramen teeth can be
damaged by dental decay fractures and
all the reasons this exposes the pulp to
bacteria from saliva that may retain it
is treated the problem may increase and
symptoms such as pain and swelling can
occur eventually the pop space becomes
completely infected with bacteria and
inflammatory response occurs resulting
damage to the bone around the root often
appearing as a dark shadow on a dental
radiography once these problems of
course there are only two ways to solve
it it either strike the tooth or carry
out a procedure called root canal
treatment root canal treatments can
often be performed in one two or more
visits and involves several steps in the
first step an access cavity preparation
is made to reach the top space and allow
the location of the canals within the
root once access has been gained to the
pulp space and root canals has been
located
the canals must be enlarged using a
variety of instruments and techniques
the prepared canals are then irrigated
with a variety of cleaning solutions the
irrigation process removes residual
affected about tissue debris from the
preparation of the canals and also
bacteria
you
after shaping and cleaning the canal
space it must be filled with a proper
material how l field canal can prevent
bacteria from infecting the tooth again
once the treatment has been completed
and following a period of Halley the
tissues around the root to return to
normal and radiographs will show the
resolution of any shadow which means a
bone lesion around the roots the
invention of x-ray computed tomography
provided a significant step forward in
diagnostic medicine CT produces a
two-dimensional map of x-ray absorption
into a two-dimensional slice of the
object this is achieved by taking a
series of x-ray projections through the
slice in different angles around an axis
perpendicular to the slice from this set
of projections the x-ray absorption map
is computed by taking a number of slices
at three-dimensional map can be produced
in 1990 Toshiba in Matsumoto in Japan
were the first out restitute suggest and
evaluate the feasibility of CT imaging
in method on Tech's because of high
costs inadequate software and low with
spatial resolution
they concluded that CT had only limited
usefulness in endodontics as the
producing images were not accurate a
decade after the CT scanner was
developed elliot and over developed the
first high-resolution x-ray micro
computed tomographic device the
so-called micro CT
however application of micro CT
technology to an adult research was
recognized only after 13 years and
described it in a paper entitled micro
computed tomography an advantage system
for detail in the doctor research in
this article alters evaluated the
reliability of using micro CT in the
reconstruction of the external an
internal anatomy of for maxillary first
molars assessing the morphological
changes in the root canal after
instrumentation and of iteration using
an isotropic resolution of 127
micrometers the authors concluded that
micro CT had potential as an advance
system for dental research with further
developments in micro CT scanners
improvements in the speed of data
collection resolution and image quality
yelled at greater accuracy compared with
the first studies using computational
methods with voxel size is decreasing to
less than 40 micrometers micro CT could
now offer the possibility of learning
tooth morphology by an interactive study
of surface rendered images and slices
and contribute to the development of
virtual reality techniques for ended on
key teaching the first attempt to use
micro CT for a quantitative analysis of
root canal anatomy was done in 1999
alters correlated the shape of the root
canals to the corresponding roots of
five maxillary molars a scan it at a
resolution of 33 micrometers in the
following year Peter and colleagues
studied the potential of micro CT for
detailing the root canal geometry of 12
maxillary molars regarding some
morphological parameters including
volume surface area diameter and
structure model index nowadays this
non-invasive non-destructive
high-resolution technology is considered
the most important and accurate research
tool for this study of root canal
anatomy the anatomy of the root canal
system is often complex and from a
clinical point of view it is important
for the clinician to be aware of this
variability in order to implement an
appropriate treatment plan and increase
the success height of in the danske
procedures because of the non
destructive nature of micro CT this
technology can be used for a precise and
accurate characterization of the root
and root canal anatomy
according to a recent comprehensive
reveal on retinal morphology using micro
CT a total of 37 root canal
configuration types have been described
which probably include the most common
anatomical configuration that can be
observed in a single root qualitative 3d
analysis can also be applied to evaluate
the presence
in location of older anatomical
landmarks such as Eastman says accessory
canals and apical ramifications in the
literature micro-ct studies on root
canal anatomy evaluated anatomical
variations present in specific groups of
teeth including the second canal in the
media book a root of maxillary first
molars three routed mandibular premolars
and molars the digital image is acquired
by microcytic are a geometric
representation of the internal and
external morphology of teeth therefore a
morphometric characterization of the
root canal system can be performed
through geometric concepts and
morphological operations applied to the
vineyard images in the first research
studies on root canal anatomy using
conventional methods quantitative
morphological data were obtained from
measuring 2d parameters
acquired from a few cross section of the
route including area perimeter diameter
and aspect ratio in the past images of
the root canals were recorded together
with a scale that allowed for further
calibration of the required software the
operator was responsible for carefully
tracing the contour of this structure to
be measured by clicking and releasing
the computer mouse button until the
results were displayed therefore
outcomes of studies using sectioning
routes were highly influenced by the
operator using micro CT technology 2d
parameters can be accurately measured
and plotted on graphs in hundreds of
slices at once this is one of the
greatest advantage of micro CT
technology over the conventional methods
to study the morphology of the root
canal system in the past the can of
shaving section at roots who was
qualitatively classify as round flat
oval or irregular shaded despite its
applicability a palliative evaluation is
always subjective and may lead to
inaccurate comparisons among studies
performance in different research
centers micro CT has opened new
possibilities for describing the
cross-section of appearance of the root
canal by means of two morphometric
parameters roundness and form-factor
roundness of a discrete 2d object is
defined by this formula where a is the
area MD max is the major diameter of the
root canal the value of roundness ranges
from zero to one with one signifying a
circle form factor can be calculated by
this equation where a and p.m. at the
root canal area and perimeter
respectively allegation of individual
objects results in small values of firm
factor in valuation of root canal shape
using these parameters in single rooted
K knives have demonstrated different
cross-sectional forms throughout the
root canal in the same specimen
description of 3d geometry of the root
canals using convention of sectioning
methods can only be estimated but never
acquired precisely
therefore this is one of the best
advantages of using non-destructive
methods such as micro CT in the study of
the internal anatomy of teeth 3d
analysis of the root canal using micro
CT algorithms
allows for the calculation of volume and
surface area volume is defined as the
volume of been arising root canal within
the volume of interest while surface
area is the total area that the surface
of the canal occupies within the volume
of interest the clinical significance of
such parameters has been emphasized by
studies demonstrating that variations in
canal geometry before preparation
procedures have a greater effect on the
changes that occurred on the root canal
system than that of the preparation
techniques another important treaty
parameter of root canals that can be
measured using micro CT is the structure
model index or as an eye as an eye is
impossible to achieve using conventional
methods such as radiography or route
sexually
this parameter reflects the geometric 3d
shape of the root canal and has been
used in comparative studies of different
groups of teeth the similarities in SM
high values among teeth must be taken
into consideration to resample selection
studies or root canal preparation as it
might compromise the final outcome
recently
your son and I are closed to validate a
new parameter to describe the 3d
geometry of the root canals name it I
rot index results from this research
will be published soon in the last 7
years our group published several papers
in which the previously mentioned 2d and
3d parameters acquired using sky scanned
1174 NCT and software were used to
describe the canal morphology of
different types of teeth
the endodontic access cavity is
considered the foremost step in root
canal treatment it is defined as the
opening prepared in a tooth to gain
entrance to the root canal system a
proper access cavity is crucial for
effective locating negotiating debriding
disinfecting and feeling the root canal
system traditional access preparation
are geometrically pre design it shapes
defined by the morphology of the pulp
chamber of each tooth the roof of the
pulp chamber must be completely removed
in order to locate and provide access to
the root canal orifices however
conventional preparations may remove a
large amount of dentin weakening the
dental structure and reduce its
resistance to fracture it has been
hypothesized that modification of the
original access geometry plays a crucial
role in the biomechanical responses of
tufa structures to functional forces
since the remaining dentin can serve as
a foundation for the restorative
procedures that follow in the don'tget
era P in this way new designs for in the
daunting access cavities called
conservative of contracted cavities have
been advocated in order to minimize to
three straw
her removal contracted in the Dante
cavities are considered to be an
alternative to traditional in the don t
cavities in maintaining the mechanical
stability and subsequently the long-term
survival and function of in the Don
Kelly treated teeth within this
background micro CT imaging has been
used to measure the volume of Curnow
enamel and dentin remove it by different
access preparations in an attempt to
correlate those values with results
acquired from fracture testing one study
showed that with the enlargement of
access preparation they stress on the
Prairie servic of dentin increasing
dramatically and may contribute as a
potential cause of rib fracture in other
study micro CT was used to evaluate the
relationship between some anatomical
landmarks onto the root canal in order
to apply them in the design of different
access cavity outlines in mandibular
molars authors concluded that the
outline design of the access cavalry had
a significant impact on root canal
preparation a remarkable advance in
endodontics in the last century was the
development of mechanical preparation
using nickel titanium instrument
manufacturers have experimented with
different alloy type tip taper
cross-sectional configurations rotation
modes and heat treatment to
remanufacture II in order to optimize
instruments properties indeed more than
150 brands of nickel titanium
instruments are currently available with
so many systems on the market clinicians
required an impartial evaluation of
these instruments in order to select the
most appropriate for clinical use over
the years several methodologies have
been used to evaluate root canal
preparation with these instruments
advances in no invasive micro CT
technology have brought new perspectives
on the evaluation of mechanical
preparation in the
context as it allows to courage astray
color-coded 3d models of the root canals
before and after preparation with high
accuracy in this image for example I'm
prepared and prepared canals are
represented by green and red colors
respectively unprepared and prepare
magic canals can also be quantitatively
compared regarding the percentage
frequency variations of 2d and 3d
parameters by subtracting values
obtained it for treated canals with
those obtained it's for untreated
counterparts evaluation of unprepared
canal surface areas is important because
these areas may Harbor bacterial biofilm
that may contribute to persistent
infection using micro CT measurements of
untouched with canal surface areas after
root canal preparation can be obtained
by calculating the number of static
voxels which means voxels present in the
same position of the canal surface
before in after instrumentation express
it as a percentage of the total number
of voxels present on the canal surface
as higher the percentage of untouchables
as worse can be considered the root
canal preparation canal transportation
and dentin thickness are other important
parameters to evaluate if root canal
enlargement is followed by unnecessary
dentin removal it may compromise the
tooth structure leading to retractor
okay using micro CT canal transportation
can be achieved by connecting the center
of gravity of the root canal in each
cross section through the length of the
entire route with a fitted line from the
coverage history datasets before and
after preparation using centroid values
then mean transportation in millimeters
can be calculated by comparing the
distance between the centres of gravity
at each level of the root canal dentin
wall thickness can be acquired by the
measurement of the width of
nineteen powered external root surface
perpendicular to a line that connects
the center of gravity of the root canals
after superimpositions of the datasets
before and after canal preparation
color-coded 3d models of dentin
thickness can also be created or a
qualitative evaluation of using
color-coded 3d models for a structure
thickness in a CityWalk software in
recent years the occurrence of root
fracture has become a major concern in
added-on --tx prett fracture is
currently considered as the third
leading cause of tooth loss that can
affected either sound of endodontic
elite realities in 2009 two studies
using a convention of sectioning method
associated root break formation with
canal preparation procedures since them
the phenomenon of micro crack has gained
it importance in the donkey research and
the number of publications in
high-impact peer-reviewed journals
correlating root canal preparation to
crack formation has increased laboratory
based studies concluded that large
tapered instruments can remove
substantial amounts of dentin during
root canal preparation creating lateral
forces that induce strain on the canal
wall and cause root cracks from which
tooth fractures can develop in
disagreement with previous studies using
convention of sectioning methods our
group uses micro CT to demonstrate the
lack of a causal relationship between
the development of rib fractures in cano
preparation instructed teeth more
recently we have improved the
reliability of micro CT to evaluate
route crack formation using a French
cadaver model using this method we have
proved that preparation procedure itself
cannot cause dainty no cracks in 2011 it
was demonstrated the feasibility of
non-destructive micro CT technology to
identify and quantify the accumulation
of the inti no debris in the root canal
space after preparation while preserving
sample integrity the disinfecting
effects of chemo mechanical preparation
may be additionally hampered in the
presence of complex anatomy which cannot
be properly accessed by conventional
techniques these areas may be pacted
with don t no debris generated by the
mechanical preparation accumulation of
debris is considered an undesirable side
effect of mechanical procedures and it
is clinically relevant because it could
easily harbor bacteria content away from
the disinfection procedures during root
canal treatment quantification of heart
debris can be performed by calculating
the difference between the non prepared
and prepared root canal space using post
processing procedures the sequence of
acquired imaging can be further used to
identify the debris by means of
morphological operations the presence of
material with a density similar to the
dentin regions previously occupied by
air in the non prepared root canal space
is considered debris and can be
quantified by the intersection between
images before and after canal
instrumentation the total volume of
heart tissue debris can also be
calculated and express it as the
percentage of the total kind of volume
after preparation colour-coded models of
the root canal and debris can also be
made to enable a qualitative comparison
of the match at root canals before and
after experimental procedures together
with mechanical preparation flushing
irrigant solution throughout the canal
space also acts mechanically in
chemically on debris and bacteria
colonizing the canal system efficient
irrigation protocols are required to
provide fluid penetrability to such an
extent as to accomplish microcirculation
flow throughout the intricate route
now anatomy and to counterbalance the
debridement quality obtained by the
mechanical enlargement of the root canal
space
you
in laboratory basis studies several
mental models have been using to
understand the intricate now effect of
irrigants by different irrigation
protocols including artificially created
grooves histological cross-sections
computational fluid dynamics and in vivo
use of dense solutions these
methodologies however are enabled to
measure quantitatively some factors
including the volume of the solution or
the root canal areas effectively touched
by the Aragon additionally the
destructive approach of these methods is
a major drawback
since the preoperative condition of the
root canal is unknown
micro CT technology can overcome
limitation
display it by conventional methods for
the study of red canal irrigation as it
can provide 3d quantitative volumetric
and 2d mapping of the irrigant within
the root canal space using micro CT the
volume of irrigant
can be also correlated to the full canal
volume in the existence of anatomical
irregularities of debris that may
prevent its spread ability the volume of
irrigant free areas can also be
calculated and correlated for example
today regan delivery method to it
activation system irrigation needle
penetration and design grid canal
configuration amount of heart tissue
degrees or shaping protocols data can be
further subjected to inferential
statistical models to access the
relevance of different irrigation
protocols falling well known parameters
root canal bitter Asian is defined as a
procedure in which any material or a
combination of materials is place it
inside the canal after it has been
completed clean it shape it and
disinfected aiming to avoid any sort of
communication or exchange between the
root canal and surrounding tissues
conventional route feelings consists of
a core material usually good aperture
which should be closely adapted to the
root canal wall in a sealer that seals
the interface between the core in the
dead
place into the canal space employing
different techniques called lateral
compaction of Europe were chosen
doubtfully the most used and tall fruit
can have feeling technique world while
the basic protocol comprises the lateral
compaction of accessory counts
undertaking by systematically
penetrating spreaders sideways of the
main Goethe bridge account the core idea
is to maximize the volume of gear purcha
inside the canal while reducing the
layer of the sealer another technique to
a bit rate root canals is warm very cow
compaction it involves the use of
successive hated pluggers and gradually
pushing down compaction to form waves of
soft annette guru puja aiming to obtain
a homogeneous and dimensionally stable
mass of feeling material as Europe urges
hated it becomes more plastic and
therefore adapts to the regularities of
the root canal walls since the
development of the warm compaction
techniques there has been debate
regarding their superiority in
comparison to cold lateral compaction
how those studies have demonstrated that
no feeling techniques produces avoid
breaking out feeling warmth vertical
compaction is associated with a lower
percentage of volume avoid white-coat
compaction techniques suffer from
unpredictable distribution of the serum
voids within the root canal space in the
past the quality of root canal iteration
was investigated using several
laboratory basic techniques in many
studies the percentage of Europe bridge
a field area was used as a surrogate
measure of the quality of the root
feeling however most of these methods
allows only a partial evaluation of
route billing and some may create
irreversible damage to the specimens
besides inaccuracies are expected
because some feeding materials might be
lost during sample preparation
although radiography does not cause any
damage to the specimens and provides
user
information he has limited accuracy
since it's based on two-dimensional
visualization of a three-dimensional
object therefore an ideal experimental
model should allow for the preservation
of sample integrity to avoid
irreversible extruder all damaged micro
CT technology has emerged as an
important tool to evaluate with failing
procedures overcoming most of the
limitations of previous studies micro CT
enables visualization of the original
feeling as a 3d single object or
evaluation of cross-sectional images of
the root at each level the volume of the
root canal feeling occupied by the
girder purchase sealer employees can be
precisely calculated your aperture
sealer and voids can be also depicted
individually by coloring or made model
transparent however complications can
handle micro CT data programmatic and
quantitative views because of the high
density of the root feeling material is
scanning artifacts such as being
hardening in partial volume effect can
obscure details of interest or caused
the CT value of a single material void
to change in different parts of the
image this artifact sometimes makes it
impossible to differentiate materials
with similar densities although higher
energy beings associated with the use of
an attenuating feeder can be beneficial
they are less sensitive to attenuation
contrasting materials and thus may not
provide sufficient differentiation among
the features of interest for these
reasons it is important to perform
different scans with alternative
variables to determine the optimal
parameters and material combinations
before the experiment Auto root canal
treatment has been shown to be a
predictable procedure with a high degree
of success trader can also happen
impaired healing is attributed to
persistent inter ridiculous originating
from no instrumented canals or in the
complex irregularities
of the root canal system previously
treated teeth with persistent infection
might be preserved with non-surgical
treatment which attempts to re-establish
healthy periapical tissues by regaining
access to the root canal system through
removal of the original alliteration for
the cleaning and refilling therefore the
remove of as much feeding material as
possible is necessary to uncover remain
lead necrotic tissues or bacteria that
might be responsible for persistent
periapical information and thus
post-treatment disease
you
most early laboratory based studies use
a destructive and two-dimensional
methods to determine the amount of
feeling material remaining after we
treatment procedures however it is not
possible to precisely calculate the
volume of feeling material remaining
after the treatment using this method on
the other hand micro-ct approach allows
for a reconstruction and volumetric
evaluation of remaining root canal
feeling materials after different
retreatment protocols overcoming the
limitation of previous methodologies the
remaining feeling materials can be
expressed as a percentage of the initial
root feeding volume using this formula
where VB and VA mean the volume of the
feeling material beef or in after each
rig treatment stage respectively 3d
models of teeth and feeling materials
can also be constructed for a
qualitative evaluation using micro CT it
has been demonstrated that the use of
supplementary procedures such as
ultrasonic or laser irradiation during
treatment can improve the removal of
feeling residuals from the root canal
space there are other several
applications of micro CT in endodontics
which include marginal adaptational
feeling and retro feeling materials
physical chemical properties of ended
auntie material porosity
characterization of root canal sealers
feeling experimental internal research
of cavities stress distribution of Nitra
instruments cutting efficiency of
nighttime instruments development of 3d
models for mechanical testing
simulations using finite element
analysis production of 3d printed
replicas of teeth to standardize sample
for laboratory studies calcium hydroxide
removal from the root canal system
dentin removal during post space
preparation adaptation of posts Pope
of this in teeth of ancient populations
in vivo healing of periapical lesions
after non-surgical or surgical risk
analysis in small animals the importance
of preclinical training has been well
established in the literature referring
the donkey education for decades in the
donkey teaching has relied almost
exclusively on the use of natural human
teeth practice instructed teeth is a
universal method of teaching preclinical
ended on Tech's and gives the students
the opportunity to gain expertise before
moving on to patients however cross
infection control associated with the
manipulation of strata teeth along with
ethical factors are threatening this
practicing in some teaching institution
these drawbacks have stimulated the
development of alternative simulation
methods for into the donkey teaching a
transparent model tools offers a
convenient and useful method that can be
used for studying and teaching about the
morphology of teeth as it provides a
3-dimensional view of the root canal
system additionally they are
standardized it easy to obtain in
quantity do not have any risk of
infection and can be available aid for
self assessments however the hardness of
the resin and the complex internal and
external dental anatomy of the first
transferring tooth models do not
accurately represent ease the
development of micro CT basic training
replicas produced it using 3d printing
technology have improved the use of
artificial teeth for teaching proposals
despite some limitations this preaching
prototypes can be extremely valuable for
anatomical teaching purposes
additionally replicas with different
root canal complexities can be printed
as oversized models allowing the
students to hold them in their hands and
to observe details of the internal
anatomy from different views as imaging
has been adopted in the modern dental
education the Internet has been used as
an important educational tool this was
the main purpose for the creation of the
web-based study guide called the root
canal anatomy project by our group this
website has received extensive traffic
since its development in 2011 with more
than 1 million 100,000 page views the
high resolution images and videos
available for download that this website
can be freely used or attributed
non-commercial educational proposal by
educators scholars students and
clinicians one of the most interesting
resources available to download that
this website includes vxm files of all
groups of teeth a V exam file contains
both the volume data in associate
transfer function this format can be
used in the free volume handling app
called City walks from broker Micro City
this app runs on either iOS or Android
systems City Vox display a set of
reconstructed slices as a realistic
interactive 3d object with intuitive
navigation and manipulation of both the
object and the camera a flexible
clipping tool to produce cutaways views
background selection including custom
scenery and an imperative transfer
function control to adjust colors and
transparency in other words using a cell
phone or tablet it is possible to rotate
cut caller highlight shadow or magnify
areas of interest and more from real 3d
data sets of different groups of teeth
acquired by micro CT technology
considering that students nowaday are
habituated to use web resources digital
and interactive 3d resources may
increase the motivation of students to
learn about the internal anatomy of the
teeth
the purpose of this presentation was to
demonstrate that although the micro-ct
method it's not suitable for clinical
use in the last decade it has become a
powerful tool for in the dental research
as it offers a no invasive reproducible
and accurate technique for the
qualitative and quantitative 3d
assessment of the internal and external
anatomy of teeth applications in
experimental internal ontology are now
becoming extensive as it can produce
detailed information images of the root
canal anatomy before during and after
different ended on key procedures a
significant amount of information can be
gleaned for these scans using dedicated
software to extract morphological data
from teeth which would be otherwise
impossible to acquire this lysis can
also be recreated in any plan while data
can be presented in 2d or 3d images
micro CT digital data can allow for
preclinical training and education
regarding the fundamental procedures of
in the Donsky treatment even though
increasingly less time is devoted to
teaching the internal anatomy of teeth
in conventional curricula compared to
the development of technical skills
nowadays students and clinicians may
benefit from the sophistication of
digital imaging technology given the
constant progress in imaging technology
it is just a matter of time until the
development of less costly right
resolution micro CT system that required
only a short learning curve more
information about this topic can be
found on chapter 7 of the book micro
computed tomography in medicine and
engineering which was edited by dr. Khan
ohana and will be published in 2019 and
on the book which can now anatomy in
permanent dentition which was launched
it in 2018 but finally I would like to
express my gratitude to Bruckner micro
CT team for inviting me
to this presentation and you of course
for watching I hope you enjoyed thank
you very much
Thank You dr. Virani for your
informative presentation if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer a question
box located on the far left of your
screen questions that are not answered
life they will be followed up by email
in the coming days let's get started
Marco our first question what are the
advantages of using microscopy approach
compared to traditional method for
endodontic research well basically we
may say that a micro CT has three main
advantages compared with the
conventional methods first it is it's a
non-destructive nature it means that
micro CT allows that the same sample can
be evaluated in different stages of the
experimental procedures but more than
that
both external and internal aspects of
the entire sample can be also analyzed
simultaneously second it it is its
accuracy this is extremely important in
research as you can trust in the
quantitative data acquired during the
analysis and finally micro CT allows to
reconstruct digital cross-sections
of the whole sample and stack them to
create 3d volumes therefore it allows
the development of 3d images and videos
of the sample which can be used for
illustrating the results of the research
or even for educational purposes
alright thanks for that we have a next
one coming up what are the main research
areas in endodontics where microscopy
can be applied well nowadays micro-ct
technology has several applications in
the dodon --tx as you could hear in my
presentation however it is mostly used
to describe the morphology of teeth and
also to comprehend the effect of
different techniques and materials used
for root canal treatment and retreatment
thank you what are the most important
quantitative microscopy parameters that
can be measured in the study of root
canal anatomy evaluation of the
morphometry of the root canal is
important to understand how differences
in the morphology of teeth can influence
the root canal treatment in clinics so
root canals can be evaluated regarding
2d and 3d parameters which includes area
perimeter roundness diameter aspect
ratio volume surface area in its 3d
geometry such as structure model and rod
indexes okay thank you
maybe one last question mark nowadays
how the microscopy application used for
dental education this is a very
important question because this is a new
one and there are a lot of potential in
micro CT because micro CT is a
non-destructive and high resolution
technology it allows the possibility of
learning to the morphology by
interactive study of surface rendering
images and slices in this way micro CT
can contribute to the development of
virtual reality techniques for in the
don'tget teaching transparent prototype
replicas of teeth
for preclinical training websites
dedicated to spread images and videos of
root canal anatomy such as the root
canal anatomy project and the
development of apps for cell phones or
tablet like city Vaux that can stimulate
the self exploration of the external and
internal anatomy of the 3d model T's for
clinicians students and so on that's it
all right great thank you again
professor ver si Alli before thank you
very much Delta same thing before we go
I would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker by other
contact information you provided at a
time of registration additionally if you
miss participating in our survey it will
pop up again on your screen at the end
of this presentation your feedback is
important to us thanks for participating
we would like to thank again professor
voss kyani for his time today and his
important research we would really like
to thank left roots and our sponsor
Brooker for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand
through May 2009 P lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye
goodbye thank you very much for the
opportunity to GL and broker Marcus CT